it's great to be joined today by
Marianne Cooper who is a sociologist at
Stanford University also author of the
book cut adrift families in insecure
times
Marianne thanks so much for joining me I
found the book very very interesting and
one of the things in particular that I
found interesting is that when we talk
about
kind of establishing how families are
doing either in total or as individuals
economists will often look to measures
like the unemployment rate or wages or
how the stock market is doing and sort
of those types of indicators you've
taken a bit of a different approach as a
sociologist can you tell us maybe a
different way of evaluating how families
are doing sure sure that's what I wanted
to do with the book as I felt like there
was something really important that was
being overlooked as you're highlighting
which is that we know families are under
economic pressure we know income and
wealth and equality are growing but all
that is tracked by various statistical
measures tax records or bankruptcy
filings job reports and that really
didn't tell the human story or talk
about the human toll that all of these
pressures come to bear on families and
so what I wanted to do is understand the
day-to-day reality for families what's
it like how are they coping with all
these things so I interviewed 50
families from rich support to really
find out and what are some of the
metrics that you found maybe were more
precise or accurate or enlightening
about about making those evaluations
well what was really interesting about
what I learned from talking with people
is that the the idea that of growing
income and wealth and equality you know
the top is really moving away there's a
concentration of wealth when I started
interviewing families I found affluent
families were extremely anxious about
their economic futures they saw you know
the lack of middle-class jobs they they
too were worried about where their
children were going to end up and so
what I came away learning is that we're
all weighed down by a kind of anxiety
that's generated in uncertain times and
so this broader societal and security
that we're all feeling plays out in
really important ways in the day to day
lives that families
takes a big psychological toll this is
really interesting to me because to be
clear to the audience this is not a old
look at all the poor rich people who are
also worried about not being rich
anymore you're actually talking about a
concept from behavioral economics or at
least I interpreted it this way you tell
me if I if this is correct of hedonic
adaptation which is that once you sort
of establish a new baseline for a
standard of living or level of income or
wealth or whatever the case may be the
initial sort of satisfaction benefits
that might have come come with it
effectively go away and the new standard
of living becomes a baseline and the
potential loss of that standard of
living is just as anxiety causing as
what you might have experienced at a
lower level of income those are not
that's not the language you apply to it
but I saw that in the way that you
described it is there something to that
it builds on that it's related to it but
it's a little bit distinct so one thing
we should talk about is the shift in
risk that's occurred over the last few
decades so um it used to be that we
shared risk with employers in other
words they would provide benefits and we
would work really hard and use our
talents to help build up a company that
kind of social contract started to
change and over time government and
employers we're really shifting risk
onto individuals and their families you
can think of a quintessential example as
the shift from pensions to 401ks used to
receive pensions now everyone's on the
hook to save whatever money they can and
also bear out the risks of any you know
investments that go wrong so there's
actually been a shift in responsibility
for creating security as well as costs
have gone up exponentially and we don't
have as many middle-class jobs anymore
so when affluent families who are you
know reading the paper and listening to
the news see all of this and they see
how difficult it is out there just to
have a normal middle-class life they get
really concerned about what this means
for their kids and as we know the
economic returns financial returns for
going to college and even graduate
school are so important and so what's
really amping up they're worried is a
sense that you know it's no longer sort
of a done
deal anymore that my kid just goes to
college and then will get a really good
job and they'll be okay that's not
that's not the situation anymore and so
that they're reading those kinds of tea
leaves and saying if I want my kid to
end up where I am something else has to
happen and so in response to all the
insecurities they want to create like an
economic firewall between their family
and this insecurity and that requires a
lot of money and a lot of positioning of
children and I write a lot in the book
about one particular family so much is
focused on making sure children can get
into really top universities because
that is seen as sort of the golden
ticket to protecting them giving them as
much you know educational credentials
and skill sets as possible and so the
anxiety in that project is immense so
I'm certainly not saying oh the poor
rich but it's it's interesting and says
something that even the most advantaged
people and an increasingly unequal
system are really really worried you
mentioned college in education there's a
few different areas that I want to go
into more detail with but since you
mentioned College let's talk about that
a little bit you interviewed more than
50 families for the book there there's a
significant awareness in society that if
college costs sort of continue
increasing at the rate that they've been
increasing and the wage reward for those
degrees does not increase in proportion
to that which it's not in other words
the degree is relatively more expensive
compared to what you would expect to
earn at a certain point some people say
there's going to have to be some kind of
breaking point and it's going to have to
require some kind of major restructuring
or reckoning or simply the the you may
see a move away from even going to
college and a significant decrease in
college enrollment or some kind of major
change how much did that dynamic factor
into the families you talk to conception
of college education and bigger picture
how are you thinking about what what
those numbers sort of point to so among
affluent families college was seen as
the equivalent of high school it was not
seen as something that guaranteed
anything and graduate school was
really really important in fact I
interviewed a young teenage girl who
said to me that her family had so often
talked about college and graduate school
that she didn't realize they were two
different things until right so that's
just sort of a clue and a very revealing
one about the educational standards in
that in that kind of environment among
middle class families there still was
more sense that a college degree is
required they they tended to think it
would lead to a bit more security even
though many of them had college degrees
and we're dealing with some kind of
different economic pressures from the
layoffs to to cuts and pay and things
like that but there wasn't so much
concern about making sure my child gets
a graduate degree what they were really
dealing with was how are we gonna pay
for this what are we gonna do and that
kind of worry on a family kind of
ripples through and you know then
there's the financial aid and figuring
out how to do it and strategizing and
then really also very sad sad stories of
children getting into schools their
dream schools and not being able to go
because there's no way to pay for it
and running the numbers and realizing
you know it's much better if you go to a
local Community College for a bank
account than going to this top school so
what scholars often talk about is the
diverging destinies as as social classes
as we have more inequality and people
move further and further apart from each
other children start to develop
different paths and different outcomes
and so what we're likely to see and what
we're beginning to see in some recent
analysis is that the children in the
kind of top highest earning families
have graduation rates that are much
higher than everybody else I think it's
like the top ten percent of households
their children are graduating over half
of them are graduating finishing college
we're in the bottom 10% it's only 9
percent of those kids so this is really
alarming from a social mobility
perspective and the American dream
whether it's with education or any of
the other areas that you would touch on
with the more than 50 families that you
talk to
did you notice either explicitly or
implicitly I'm kind of worried this the
right way a difference in what they
blamed for the status quo
based on their political leanings in
other words were you able to determine
that those who maybe are more
conservative tended less to blame
government because they expect less from
government like as an example or you
know kind of fill in the blanks in
whatever way you might have observed
that well you know my study was done in
Silicon Valley which is a more
left-leaning place interestingly
politics didn't come to the surface very
much and I think what's happening is I
took a step back is when people
experience insecurity they experience it
as a personal failing they don't they're
not immediately thinking about the
policy failures that led to the outcome
so for example I I got to know a woman
in Laura Delgado who was going through a
divorce and downward mobility when I met
her her life was really falling apart in
a lot of ways and fears before I met her
she had had a seizure and I'm while
driving got in a car accident had you
know thousands of tens of thousands of
dollars in medical bills and when she
talked about that that you know putting
her family in debt she talked about how
we should have had health insurance
well they had forgotten health insurance
because her husband had recently gotten
a job that didn't provide health
insurance so that's a moment where you
can imagine many different responses to
that happening to someone someone's been
saying it's not fair that I don't have
health insurance it's not okay that I
get in an accident that's beyond my
control and not only is it seeking me
but it's gonna think my kids and their
futures interestingly people really
thought about what they could have done
how they could have acted differently
when oftentimes there really wasn't a
different way to act and that really
prevented a political understanding and
political sort of demands on changing
the system it's hard to understand how
we have such high levels of inequality
in this country without people
protesting more or even rioting in the
streets when you actually look at the
numbers and we have some unprecedented
levels going back to you know the Gilded
Age and so people are talking themselves
through this experience they're working
on their emotions they're they're sort
of downplaying their anxiety
middle-class working-class families are
because they really feel like these
problems are so much so big so beyond
them that
to focus on what they individually can
do but by doing that it kind of eclipses
the larger the rod larger dynamics of
policy failures that have created the
problems that they're enduring did you
get a sense of why we're not seeing more
civil disobedience strategic defaults I
mean we've talked a lot on my program
about there is more one can do than just
writing to your elected officials and
signing petitions online that being said
many times people don't feel that it's
bad enough yet to go to that sort of
next level did you get any insight into
what it would take to get to that kind
of next level of protest and civil
disobedience over the over the
structural problems that we're seeing
that's a great question I mean so what I
you know where's the affluent families
my study we're striving for more and
more the working class the middle-class
families are really trying to get used
to less like that's how they were coping
with this is really scaling back their
definitions of security Laura Delgado
said to me you know having nothing isn't
always a bad thing she tried to make
this really difficult situation more
tolerable though their electricity got
turned off because they couldn't pay the
bill and she described the the night
that it happened to me and she said but
it's okay it was like camping because me
and the kids are in the living room you
know huddled under our sleeping bags the
intensity of the economic difficulty is
so hard that people cope in whatever way
they can and I think it become can
become extremely difficult to kind of
link up your individual situation with
these policy failures on a higher order
on so many jobs not having health
insurance on so many jobs not paying
good wages so the moment in which
someone can take their individual
insecurity and link it up with something
in a way that galvanizes them is really
important to understand part of it is
the stories around them and the
frameworks around them that they can use
to make sense of the world and
unfortunately this anti-government
big-government narrative is also
available and sometimes that can leave
people to turn the blame back on
themselves yeah well I mean I'm thinking
as you say that it seems as though there
are there are individuals and
organizations that benefit from people
like the ones you talk to
not making that connection I mean a
great example right now is the idea of
the undocumented immigrant lowering
wages for Americans and the focus on the
immigrant looking to work rather than
the corporation that's so willing to
hire them and it seems that if more
people made the connection maybe that
would catalyze more activism yeah I mean
really understanding how social change
happens how people get highly
politicized is such an important
question to ask when you think about it
it's partly we just need to go back to
history and understand you after the the
Great Depression how did people come to
think that government had an obligation
to give them security provide them with
security really it took you know an
unemployment rate of you know almost a
quarter or whatever it was at the height
of it that Soma it was so much bigger
than any individual person you could no
longer blame yourself and so it's
talking about how of course we can all
make better decisions but it's there
growing in income and wealth inequality
in our country is not because
individuals aren't making the right
decisions it's not because people aren't
working hard it's because the system is
unfair and people can no longer
translate working hard into moving up
and so I think it's providing
alternative frameworks and different
ways of understanding the things that
happen to people but America is a
country deeply rooted in individualism
which has a lot of benefits but it also
can serve just kind of obscure some of
the larger dynamics and social forces
that come down and you know their their
pressures on families you know when a
husband and wife that are having a fight
about you know not enough money they're
not thinking about you know policy trade
policy and how that actually is the the
lard they're wrapping around their fight
absolutely the book is called cut adrift
families and insecure times we've only
touched on some of the topics that Mary
Ann Cooper discusses in the book thanks
so much for talking to me about this
today thanks it's good to be here